l'attaque avait pour cible la résidence
privée du Général Robert une maison
ouver au journalist ce matin pour qu'il
constê l'leur
desâts impact de B sur la façade et les
véhicules du cortège
présidentiel blind lég immobilis dans un
melon le pouvoir militaire iirien une
vingtaine d'assaillantur donn l' vers 1
he du
matinéninant itivement chassé 2 he plus
tard par la garde rapprochée du chef de
l'État et le concours de renfort
notamment de la gendarmerie le coup de
force aurait fait deux morts chez les
loyalistes pas d'information en revanche
sur les motivations des assaillants ni
sur l'identité des quelques suspects
arrêtés dans un périmètre proche du lieu
de
l'attaque vers 11h un rebergil calme et
en civil répondait à la presse sans
beaucoup plus de précision peut-on par
exemple parler d'attentat contre sa
personne
live étant donné que je n'ai pas assisté
à la préparation il me sera difficile de
donner un
titre ce que je sais c'est qu'il y a eu
des rumeurs qui ont été
confirm à vous de choisir le mot exact
dans l'entourage du général pourtant ce
matin on ne se privait pas d'évoquer des
commanditair tapis dans l'ombre dans
leurs villas abidjanaises et beaucoup de
reconnaître dans ce portrait Alassan
Ouara l'ancien Premier ministre de
foubani et ses partisans des partisans
qui se relaent devant la demeure de leur
leader depuis 48h redoutant son
arrestation à nouveau les armes ont
parlé dans les rues d'Abidjan une bien
curieuse manière de se préparer à
l'élection présidentielle toujours prévu
le 22 octobre prochain comme l'ont
confirmé les militaires une élection à
laquelle Robert gay et Alassan Ouatara
sont tous deux
candidat